[MUSIC].
Welcome to the first ever Sense Olympics. I'm joined here by my co-host Andy.
Thanks for joining us Andy.
&gt;&gt; Thanks for having me, Lauren. I'm really excited to be here. Let's start by
telling some of our viewers at home what we're going to be doing in the Sense
Olympics.
&gt;&gt; That sounds like a good idea.
&gt;&gt; So, we're going to have six events. And, we're going to be using our coworkers
as senseletes. Now, each of these events is going to somehow test or push the
limits of human sense and perception. And first we have a touch event. And in
this event, we're going to be measuring what's called a difference threshold.
So, basically, measuring our senseletes ability to detect small changes in
weight.
&gt;&gt; Then, we're going to move on to one of our chemical senses. That's taste.
Followed by our main events that focus on hearing and seeing.
&gt;&gt; As we all know, humans have five senses. They have sight, hearing, taste, smell
and touch. And to go along with each of those five senses are our five sense
organs. We have eyes, ears, nose, tongue and skin. And it's through these
organs that we receive all of our sensory information about the world.
&gt;&gt; That's true, Andy. But our sensory organs are just the beginning of the
process. They only let us sense things, not necessarily perceive them.
&gt;&gt; You're right. And this is a really important distinction, sensation versus
perception. So, sensation is really the taking in of input. It's the sights and
the sounds. Whereas perception is the understanding and interpreting of these
inputs. So, really it's the senses.
&gt;&gt; Or sensations.
&gt;&gt; Together with the brain.
&gt;&gt; Or our perception.
&gt;&gt; That are part of really the same process. Responding adaptively to our
environment.
&gt;&gt; So what's really important here, is that we see, feel, touch, taste, and hear
just as much with our brain as we do with our sense organs. Sensation is just
the beginning of the process. Whereas perception is the end of the process. Oh,
excuse me, I'm getting word from our grounds correspondent, Susan. Their
senseletes are lining up to begin. You know, while we're waiting for them to
start, Andy, do you mind telling the people at home what it takes to be a
senselete?
&gt;&gt; Absolutely, Lauren. So one thing we can expect to see today, from our real
all-star contenders is some exquisite transduction. Now, transduction is
something you may not be familiar with. It's how we convert a physical stimulus
and the physical energy associated with that into neural energy, in the form of
neural impulses.
&gt;&gt; For example, when light waves become neural impulses from the photo receptors
on our retna.
&gt;&gt; That's true Lauren, but I think we're getting a little ahead of ourselves.
&gt;&gt; I'm sorry, I just get really excited about sensation of perception.
&gt;&gt; It's okay, Lauren, we all do. It's going to be a great day in the history of
Sense Olympics though.
&gt;&gt; Andy, you do know it's going to be the only day in the history of Sense
Olympics.
&gt;&gt; You don't know that. This might be a continuing event. I hope so. anyway,
before we begin the first event, we'd love to thank our sponsors who made this
a reality. Paint away, sniff book, Megadog 30,000 desiboost and
[UNKNOWN].
They've generously donated to make this event happen. So, now to our ground
correspondent, Susan, are you ready?